Speaker 1: We still don't have many of the
results from last night's primaries, and we
don't yet have the results for Cory Lake,
a Republican running in Arizona.
But the new thing now among Republicans is
you just claim that there is fraud even before
the election has started.
And that's exactly what Cory Lake did.
This video is from Monday night.
On Monday night.
Remember the United States?
We vote on Tuesday.
The election was last night, but on Monday
night, Vaughn Hilliard from MSNBC confronted
Arizona gubernatorial Republican candidate
Kari Lake, who is a big Trump brown noser
and suck up because she's already saying that
there is voter fraud.
And see if you can find the list of things
she does here that exposed her as an obvious
Trump acolyte.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Your order contending that there
is irregularities and there is fraud in this
election.
At what point does Terry Lake stop and say,
am I undermining merit faith in our election
and I help bring that to America?
But you haven't even laid out any fraud for
a regular.
But whatever it is, they're hearing what's
right is there.
This is serious about you know, this is about
Arizona voters and their faith in this election.
Unidentified: One person, one man.
So you know about a crime.
Speaker 5: And yet you're not reporting it
for the audience and I'm not.
Speaker 1: Telling you.
Okay.
All right.
So let's look at the list of things that Kerry
Lake did there that expose her as an obvious.
Trump is number one.
She referred to herself in the third person,
referring to herself as Carrie like.
Remember that Trump would always say They
want Trump.
They want Trump.
He calls MSNBC, MBS, DNC.
That's straight out of the Trump playbook.
She claims that there was voter fraud before
the election, has actually been before the
vote has been tallied, before elections.
The results have been published.
That's a classic Trump thing.
Of course, Trump famously doing that in 2020,
in the lead up to the 2020 election for about
six months.
And then she claims that there is a crime,
but she won't tell us what the crime is.
And remember, Trump did that with Obama.
Remember Obama gate?
I don't even remember at this point what Obama
gate was even supposed to be because Trump
never told us.
And when reporters would say there was one
reporter in the press briefing room who said,
What is Obama gate?
And Trump angrily said, You know what it is?
But he never actually told us, just insisting
it was the biggest crime of the century or
something like that.
So apparently it's not just Democrats who
steal elections, it's also other Republicans
in primaries.
I guess it's non-Trump Republicans.
Now, as of this moment, Carrie Lake is leading
but has not won her primary.
I would love it if Carrie Lake lost her primary.
Hold on a second.
We're not even able to see this accurate.
There we go.
Carrie Lake, currently with 80% reporting,
Carrie Lake at 46%.
And the second place candidate, Karen Taylor
Robson at 44%.
And remember, this is the Republican primary
merely to determine who in November will face
Katie Hobbs.
Katie Hobbs easily winning the Democratic
primary.
One thing that you will notice is that more
people voted in the Republican primary than
the Democratic there in Arizona.
And we will see what that suggests might happen
in November.
But at least for now, it would be an absolute
delight if Carrie Lake ends up losing.
She is ahead by about 12, about 11,000 and
a half votes right now with one out of five
votes still to be counted.
But there's already voter fraud.
Now, if she wins, what will she say about
voter fraud?
Will she say there was none?
Of course not.
If she wins, she will say there was voter
fraud, just not enough to steal the election
from me.
That's the deal.
And we'll have that clip of Carrie Lake speaking
to Von Hilliard on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show.